[Music]
i'll count down when you can open your
eyes okay okay three
two
one
surprise
oh my
[Music]
i god to cry go go look go look touch
feel
[Music]
i love this is so sexy
sexiness oh my god this veil
oh my cry i'm so happy thank you guys
i love it so am i married it's happening
it's really hard
oh my god
oh i'm just like taking this anime
one time so happy i know very happy
thank you so happy it's your baby
the wedding gown is even more beautiful
than princess grace kelly's and the veil
is so long all the details
i am just
over the moon
is that insane
all hand done
that's all hand done every single star
is handed out
this is not a fabric you know her
nickname is star yes so i wanted stars
when you said the stars i i didn't know
it would be this sick like this is so
out of control don't step on the veil
not
is it cute too oh my goodness
yes
i love this 3d effect
like a little like ballerina bride
like mixed with like a goddess very
looks like it should be in a museum
all right let's get going you're going
to miss your flight yes
get naked go let's do this living oh
look at the flower girl dresses what
is with her dress yes they're so excited
to be flower girls yeah
have they been rehearsing no
do they know what it entails
no
they're just very excited we're gonna
wear a pretty dress
and throw petals
wow look at that corset looking so good
you look like a doll
yes
the veil was a surprise
do you know that she thought the
surprise you were talking about was the
dress lighting up
this is a better surprise can i put your
hair in a bun just to see like the idea
of it back
it's obviously going to be prettier on
no i want you to do my hair for me
that is so beautiful back yeah i like it
back
carter loves my hair up
james loves my hair up too
so what do i do
nothing just tell us what you'd like
what you don't like oh do you want the
arms taken in do you want oh yeah should
we make the arms a little yeah
and a little longer
i open this a little yeah and push it up
so it's against right
i feel like because i love wearing
chokers so i feel like yeah go higher
and like like yours was high right yeah
like that princess yeah so go like
and i have a very long neck
show her so she knows where would you
like it up to here see yeah i think we
can go another inch more than an inch
like somewhere yeah go an inch and then
closer to her neck okay so like well try
to remove all of the three-dimensional
ones
around here and here so that it doesn't
add bulk i think for the arms we should
keep it very slim yeah yes so it's like
a tattoo yeah you know
this is beautiful paris i like mix can
you attach slip gloves
we're not attaching slip gloves
[Music]
oh my god this is so
stunning do you want to go longer
okay yes
stress
sit
seriously beyond
really pretty it's very maryland
yes it is this is one of the most
exciting and special moments of my life
all three dresses are so stunning i'm
just so thrilled with how they all
turned out look at her
living bride
[Music]
[Music]
you